a couple of things I've talked about
I've already come off of the OWASP top
10 risk for mobile right which is a list
that myself Jack Menino Zac lennier and
a you know a number of other people in
the application security community
collaborated on to put together this
list of top 10 risks more mobile yeah
owasp is a great organization it's owa
SP owa SP org and highly recommended for
all the geeks out there want to learn
more about security in general
application security specifically
there's various projects one that covers
mobile that you mentioned right lem that
you're involved in another a wealth of
other resources and information there so
highly recommend that sherlyn Keeks up
there check that out so one of the
things and it's actually the number to
risk on my loss mobile top 10 is to the
number to risk is essentially week
server side controls me so i basically
just consider a pointer to the original
OS top 10 for web applications which was
a you know a widely accepted list of
standards standard risks and
vulnerabilities in web applications but
they owed something that you know other
compliance organizations have taken so
for example pci to become pci compliant
you need to be scanned and assessed
based on the EOS top 10 ready so when
we're writing these new mobile
applications we need to just remember
that it's not just code going on client
anymore it's potentially a whole new
server side infrastructure either you
know so based web service or a restful
service and these you know these new
pieces of technology are right for
attack you know it's funny when the
iPads first came out you know within a
couple of days there was the first ipad
hack we're all sorts of public all sorts
of private details and data about the
you know initial customers who receive
their ipads was made public is
essentially publicly available on the
internet and the reason for this one
essentially poor server side controls
there was no access control on these web
services that the ipad was communicating
with so people could just bypass the
ipad you know my web browser talk
directly to the service extract all this
data and that was labeled as an ipad
hack really it's kind of the same thing
we've been dealing with for you know
well over a decade sequel injection
input validation attacks proper
authorization lack of access contrition
so what if I'm not starting from scratch
what if I'm a developer and I all up
already have mobile application out
there and maybe I didn't think sort of
through some of these architectural or
sensitive data storage on the time maybe
I didn't think through all those issues
when I was originally architecting my
app what's the first thing I should do
to try to secure an existing mobile
application sure I would have a I would
perform a code review more security
where someone looks at the code line by
line manually and assesses that code
based on the current boss top 10 risks
for mocha and so I could do this myself
as a developer not necessarily the
higher expensive security consultant I
could go to the l oz and start to work
my way through the top 10 and do a code
review of my own application for example
certainly I mean something as simple as
you know data storage on the device you
know if you're storing sensitive data on
the SD card if you see yourself doing
that that's bad because that's a
basically a public location on the
device and the application can access it
so yeah I think it's it's certainly
doable for a developer to start working
through these risks and analyzing their
own code how can the geeks reach out to
you if they have questions about an
application security sure well you can
always just Google me Mike Sussman and a
number of things will pop up my blog
will pop up you can also find me on
twitter my handle is jointly know ok
which is not as easily spell misspell it
up for us SCH mo i L I T oh ok nothing I
always forget that last time yeah and a
navy companies carves his car system
great awesome well thanks for trying
this yeah thanks be security is a great
topic it's something I want to cover
more like I said in future episodes so
maybe we'll bring you back and do a
deeper dive the shirts that only they
know after they did perhaps sure okay
definitely Greg hasn't